what would happen if you put a couple of
physicists in a room with a rope a box
and a black hole they might come up with
a plan to power the earth for centuries
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we could harness the energy of
a black hole black holes aren't
something you come across every day to
make a black hole of your own you'd have
to squeeze a star ten times bigger than
our Sun into a sphere the diameter of
New York City
black holes are very dense and have
enormous mass and as we know from a
famous Albert Einstein equation
everything that has mass also has energy
in the case of a black hole we're
talking a whole lot of energy
theoretically we could collect all that
power without any super advanced new
tech and if we did we'd have access to
more energy than we'd know what to do
with but of course it's not that easy
what makes black holes such an
attractive energy source it's their high
energy conversion rate let's do some
math take a three kilogram kitten and
multiply his mass by the speed of light
squared you'll see that the energy
contained within this one little kitty
is enough to power up six point four
million American homes for a year but
you could never extract all that energy
from a cat the best energy producers we
have right now nuclear fission and
nuclear fusion only gather point zero
eight and zero point seven percent of
the potential energy in mass black holes
are a different story their energy
conversion rate sits around the 40% mark
but finding a black hole wouldn't be
easy with today's available technology
even getting into the neighborhood of a
black hole will take you about 12
million years so let's fast forward and
assume that we've found a black hole
nearby how would we go about getting the
most out of it
we could try throwing stuff into the
black hole the gravitational pull of a
black hole would cause anything dropped
into it to speed up and release energy
as it went or we could drop things into
the accretion disk of a black hole where
all the dust particles are caught in its
orbit from there we'd be collecting
energy in the form of radiation
something known as the Penrose process
but how exactly would we collect all
this energy some great minds have come
up with a theory that a box designed to
collect energy could be sent from a safe
distance point via a rope to a location
close to a black hole's event horizon
filling with radiation in the process
one problem here is ensuring that the
box in the rope don't get sucked into
the hole according to some calculations
the box suitable for this task could
only be the size of bacteria so that the
rope could still support it we might as
well dip strings right into the event
horizon and drain a black hole
completely dry it would take a very very
long time but once it's done the most
ambitious energy dreams would come true
we could abandon our power plants and
finally stop polluting the planet we
could fuel up our rockets and go explore
outer space we'd start building mega
structures in space the things we could
do with unlimited energy but first we'd
need to spend millions of years
traveling to a suitable black hole that
is unless we could develop a warp drive
technology to speed things up but that's
a story for another what-if
[Music]